public sénat france 24 et rfi présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ici
l'europe cette semaine européenne est
toujours sous le signe d'interrogation
sur la stratégie vaccinale de l'union et
la croissance soutenable poste qu vide
et pour en parler nous recevons
l'eurodéputé français vers yannick jadot
votre actualité de la semaine d'ailleurs
c'est votre rapport sur la taxation aux
frontières taxation carbone de l'ue eux
bonjour à vous il ya des gens militant
de toujours de la cause écologiste vous
êtes élue au parlement européen en 2009
et depuis vous n'avez pas quitté les
bancs de cette assemblée très bien réélu
en 2019 à la tête de la liste europe
écologie les verts elle est arrivée en
troisième position avec eu plus de 13%
des suffrages exprimés
une farce électorale qui vous donnent
des ailes depuis vous faites partie des
candidats pressentis pour la
présidentielle de 2000 22
alors il ya un exocet semaine apparaît
plus fragmenté que jamais et
l'union européenne incapable de
maîtriser sa stratégie vaccinale alors
que les britanniques qui viennent de
nous quitter font clairement mieux en
réussi leur coupe réussissent leur
campagne de vaccination ça vous étonne
l'union européenne quant à elle s'est
saisie de la vaccination à une très
bonne initiative qui était l'idée de
regrouper les capacités des différents
états membres en matière de négociation
et d'achats de vaccins
l'union européenne s'est pas beaucoup
trompé finalement sur les sociétés qui
ont été chaque liste et qu'on était
retenue il y avait plus de 150 candidats
finalement la plupart des laboratoires
qui ont été retenus vont fournir des
vaccins
et puis l'idée d'acheter collectivement
et qui n'y est pas autour des vaccins ce
qui avait eu autour des masques les
états européens ce volant les masques y
compris sur les tarmacs chinois l'idée
de travailler ensemble
c'était une très bonne idée la
difficulté qu'on a eu c'est que les
personnes qui ont géré la négociation
avec les laboratoires n'étaient pas les
bonnes personnes
c'était il aurait fallu plus tôt
d'ailleurs maintenant il est dans le jeu
c'est le commissaire breton qui connaît
les firmes qui connaît les situations de
crise et qu'ils les abords d'un point de
vue industriel
il aurait fallu quelqu'un de beaucoup
plus dynamique beaucoup moins frileux à
la fois pour négocier avec les
laboratoires
finalement la question du prix quand on
voit le coût de cette pandémie est assez
anecdotique presque mais surtout même
tapé du poing sur la table pour avoir
des quantités massifier la production et
l'accès au vaccin
alors dites-nous yannick jadot vous avez
eu des mots très forts il ya quelques
jours vous
lle porté plainte contre la commission
européenne nous avons engagé ce bras de
fer avec la commission européenne pour
dire nous voulons les citoyens européens
méritent la transparence sur ces
contrats donc on est dans ce dans le
processus d' échange de l'aide parce que
c'est un processus très encadré des
changes de l'être avec la commission
pour bien garantir que la commission ne
veut pas être transparents et
effectivement nous irons devant la cour
de justice européenne pour imposer la
commission son devoir de transparence
sur la question des quelques états qui
aujourd'hui s'adressent à d'autres
fournisseurs d'autres laboratoires
que ce soit les laboratoires où il ya
déjà des autorisations mais aussi
évidemment les vaccins russe c'est des
vaccins chinois mois-ci là je crois que
la seule réponse à ça c'est à la fois
aujourd'hui pour l'union européenne 2
d'imposer ce qu'on appelle la licence
obligatoire c'est à dire qu'en fait
c'est dans le droit français dans le
droit européen dans le droit
international
on récupère les brevets on compense les
laboratoires mais on récupère les
brevets pour massifier la production en
situation de crise sociale de crise
économique de crise sanitaire évidemment
de détresse psychologique mayer majeur
dans l'ensemble du monde on se laisse
ballotter par l'agenda des laboratoires
qui veulent évidemment récompenser leurs
recherches mais franchement l'europe va
dépenser probablement 20 milliards
d'euros ou plus dans la vaccination
pareil pour les états unis
est-ce qu'on peut pas aujourd'hui mettre
les équipes de pfizer de moderna
d'astrazeneca et d'autres autour de la
table pour nous faire les meilleurs
vaccins
les vaccins qui y compris répondront aux
variants qui sont déjà là ou qui vont
arriver et qu'on dise on met le paquet
sur les capacités de production pour
massifier la la vaccination chez nous et
dans le reste du monde
et parce que si on vaccine pas le reste
du monde tous
frash chez nous pour être totalement
percuté par de nouveaux variants au
lycée on se laisse un ballet pas tout le
monde en tout cas un certain mario
draghi qui vient à peine d'arriver à la
tête de l'italie bloque désormais
l'exportation des vaccins astrazeneca
vers l'australie avec d'ailleurs la
bénédiction de la commission européenne
lui a demandé de le faire
et est-ce que c'est comme ça qu'on va
gagner notre bras de fer avec les labos
il faut arrêter je les dis on se fait
ballotter manipulés par les laboratoires
et notamment astrazeneca qui nous avait
promis beaucoup de doses on a beaucoup
investi sur astrazeneca c'est 350
millions d'euros pour leur permettre de
produire et on sait que astrazeneca a
très largement favorisé la grande
bretagne
ça lui permet de vacciner beaucoup plus
a réduit la fourniture de doses à
l'union européenne malgré les
engagements et potentiellement
exporterait sur d'autres pays donc la
question n'est pas de se replier sur
nous-mêmes de vouloir nous vacciner tout
seul au détriment du reste du monde mais
c'est d'avoir un rapport de force
équilibrés avec les labos astrazeneca a
promis des doses on a payé
astrazeneca ne peut pas délocaliser
j'allais dire une partie des doses qui
nous sont promises c'est bien que ce
soit l'union européenne ce qu'ils
imaginaient la france on serait planté
que notre sanofi parce qu'en plus on a
laissé partir
vale neva qui vous savez être ce
laboratoire près de nantes laboratoire
français qui va avoir un vaccin avant
sanofi on l'a laissé partir en écosse et
fournir des vaccins la grande bretagne
donc heureusement qu'à l'europe pour
nous la france
mais l'europe aujourd'hui il doit
imposer un agenda beaucoup plus
ambitieux sur les brevets sur la
production et la vaccination au
laboratoire pour l'europe et pour le
reste du monde et pour le reste du nord
l'agencé européenne des médicaments est
en train d'examiner le vaccin en russe
le spoutnik v moscou propose même
et des millions 50 millions un jour 100
millions le lendemain pour l'europe
cette diplomatie vaccinale c'est une
claque pour les européens c'est une
claque pas pour tous les européens
reconnaissons le en allemagne ils ont
failli there et biotech
ils ont curva qu ils ont quand même deux
laboratoires qui fournissent des vaccins
mais c'est surtout une claque pour la
france c'est le seul granby le seul pays
au conseil de sécurité qui n'a pas sans
vaccin ce qu'ils ont dit long sur l'état
de notre recherche fondamentale et
l'état des relations entre l'état et des
laboratoires qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
assez investi qui est la diplomatie
chinoise en chinant en afrique notamment
il ya de la diplomatie russe un peu
partout dans le monde
moi on doit pas faire de politique sur
les vaccins soient ils répondent aux
critères de l'agencé européenne et ils
doivent être validés et tant mieux si on
accède à des doses soient ils ne
répondent pas aux critères et aux
autorisations et il faut l'éviter là
aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait c'est que
l'union européenne notamment l' agence
européenne du médicament est en train de
collaborer avec notamment les
laboratoires russes notamment pour faire
valider des processus de production
on nous dit en permanence ah non on peut
pas reprendre l'élevage un arn messagers
les produire dans d'autres unités de
production que l'unité original non
novartis va le faire va le faire sur
d'autres vaccins notamment sur cure vac
cure vague qui est soutenu par
l'équivalent de l' agence française de
développement en allemagne kfw par la
fondation gates et qui va y compris
produire des vaccins pour le monde
entier
et ça c'est la bonne nouvelle c'est la
bonne approche et curve ac est le seul
labo à dire moi je suis prêt pour les
licences obligatoires
je suis prêt à partager ma recherche
mais brevets pour qu'on vaccine le monde
imposons ça aux autres la bri qu'on est
au chapitre de la russie quand même les
27 ont pris une série de sanctions
contre des personnalités russes en
représailles à l'arrestation de
l'opposant alexeï navalni faut-il aussi
allé jusqu'à bloquer la construction du
gazoduc nord stream 2 vous dites oui et
en même temps vous êtes écologistes vous
avais pas très envie que ceux qui se
substitue la saison le gaz de schisme
américain ah non quand on est écologie
ce canton et écologistes et d'ailleurs
c'est ce que nous portons auprès des
institutions européennes depuis des
années c'est que si on met le paquet sur
notamment l'isolation des bâtiments en
europe on n'aura pas besoin du gaz russe
on n'aura pas besoin de 15 ans dans
l'europe en europe vers l'allemagne qui
veut dire et la france voudrait dire
quand même c'est extraordinaire on
pourrait en mettant le paquet sur ce qui
crée de l'emploi sur ce qui réduit nos
consommations d'énergie sur ce qui
protège le climat on pourrait se passer
du gaz russe et donc de cette
complaisance vis-à-vis de poutine
nous n'avons pas de politique extérieure
commune souvenez-vous de l'humiliation
du représentant de l'union européenne
pour la politique extérieure aurel quand
il va à moscou et qui la prend devant la
presse que les diplomates européens sont
expulsés ce qui veut dire que nous
n'avons pas cette puissance nous n'avons
pas de politique de défense et on nous
rajoutons à cela que nous n'utilisons
pas l'économie européenne comme rapport
de force avec la russie avec la chine il
suffirait vous savez le le le
l'oligarchie poutinienne elle vit de
gasprom y vivent de ça si à un moment
donné on bloque north stream 2 je peux
vous dire que ça changera la politique
russe de la même façon on a un problème
avec la chine qui est une dictature
comme depuis longtemps n'en a pas vu les
ouigours toutes les autres minorités
hong kong et en même temps l'union
européenne passe un accord
d'investissement avec la chine qui va
faire que on va avoir plus encore de
complaisance et d'incapacité à poser nos
valeurs
donc si on veut porter les valeurs de
l'union européenne sur la démocratie les
libertés fondamentales
si on veut défendre notre souveraineté
économique
il faut aussi utiliser notre marché pour
imposer un changement d'attitude de la
russie comme de la chine en france vous
multipliez vous les déplacements pour
soutenir les candidats écolos régional
et aussi construire votre propre
campagne pour la présidentielle de 2000
si vous aviez été en charge puisque
c'est quand même votre visée est ce que
vous auriez gérer cette crise qu vide
autrement oui je crois que plus la
situation est incertaine
plus la détresse psychologique
s'installe avec la lassitude la crise
sociale les difficultés économiques plus
il faut travailler avec l'intelligence
collective
ça fait un an que j'ai composé avec
l'intelligence collective
ça fait un an que j'ai proposé que soit
mis en place un conseil de sécurité
sanitaire ou autour de scientifiques
autour évidemment du conseil
scientifique on mettrait aussi les
forces politiques majorité opposition
les forces sociales les entreprises des
syndicats de salariés et les
associations qui agissent au plus près
de celles et de ceux qui sont en
difficulté et qui par exemple
aujourd'hui n'arrive plus à manger à
leur faim pour que ça n'est pas supprimé
les prérogatives du président de la
république et à la fin doit arbitrer
mais c'est pour qu'il y ait un partage
du diagnostic et pour que justement on
évite les polémiques on évite
l'instrumentalisation de la clis
sanitaire où chacun y va de sa recette
et sa polémique
ce que veulent les françaises et les
français aujourd'hui je crois justement
c'est que la majorité et les oppositions
dépassent leur agenda politique
électorale pour ne s'occuper que d'une
chose ensemble de leur santé alors pour
2021 vous avez appelé à voter pour un
président qui a un rapport sain à la
démocratie est ce que ça veut dire que
si un nouveau duel
macron le pen parce que c'est
l'obsession de la classe politique en ce
moment est-ce que vous appellerez encore
ajouté emmanuel macron mais je n'ai
jamais eu aucune ambiguïté par rapport à
l'extrême droite
j'ai des concurrents ou des adversaires
en politique j'ai des ennemis en
politique ça s'appelle l'extrême droite
mais je vois aussi d'autres responsables
politiques qui en permanence remettre en
cause l'indépendance de la justice ou se
faire sarkozy bien par exemple ou le
fonctionnement de la police je vois
aussi dans ce moment où le monde va va
très vite
je suis dire c'est très difficile pour
les processus démocratiques de s'adapter
la rapidité du monde et donc justement
il faut un rapport ça la démocratie ce
qui veut dire assumer n'ont pas de
concentrer le pouvoir c'est ce que fait
le président de la république mais de
faire en sorte que dans les entreprises
et c'est ce que je propose
les salariés acquièrent du pouvoir de
codécision que on donne beaucoup plus de
pouvoir aux collectivités des
compétences moi je supporte pas les
responsables politiques qui
instrumentalisent les colères qui
instrumentalisent les peurs qui organise
des paniques identitaire aujourd'hui
dans ce pays
mais ce que je veux c'est tous les
matins on relocalise l'économie et c'est
ça la transition écologique tous les
maths en remettent de la démocratie des
services publics et de la culture et
vous verrez que si on combat tous les
jours
l'extrême droite est ce qui alimente
l'extrême droite colère sentiment
d'abandon insécurité économique et
social et ben l'extrême droite la menace
de l'extrême droite disparaîtra dans
notre pays alors le parlement vote mardi
prochain votre texte le texte dont vous
êtes le rapporteur en tout cas qui sera
d'ailleurs présenté en juin par la
commission européenne
il s'agit d'un mécanisme d'ajustement
carbone à la frontière alors on a envie
de dire qu'elle a co et puis surtout à
quoi ça va servir le produit de cette
taxation carbone en quelque sorte
si on doit décarbonés notre économie et
on a des objectifs qui vont être de
moins 55% - 60% d'ici 2030
il ne faut pas que la conséquence à soi
la désindustrialisation
c'est à dire qu'en fait des entreprises
qui considèrent que parce qu'elles sont
soumis à une politique climatique
ambitieuse vont délocaliser dans des
pays qui n'auraient pas la même ambition
climatique donc l'objectif de 7 en août
y est essentielle c'est de faire un sas
à l'entrée du marché européen
ceux qui exportent en europe de la
sidérurgie qui vont exporter du du
ciment qui vont exporter de la chimie ou
qui vont exporter l'électricité et d'un
soient soumis aux mêmes ambitions
climatiques que les entreprises
européennes
l'idée c'est que il n'y ait pas de
dumping climatique à l'entrée et les
revenus dont vous parliez on parle de 5
à 14 milliards dont vous voyez que la
fourchette est très large et ben devrait
être affectée justement à la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique et ce
qui est toujours important pour nous à
la solidarité avec dans le monde les
pays qui sont le plus touchés
aujourd'hui par le dérèglement
climatique mais qui sont souvent les
moins responsables on pense aux pays les
moins développés par merci yannick jadot
d'avoir été notre invité aujourd'hui
alors nous allons nous pencher dans la
partie des bas dans quelques minutes
avec ma camarade de public sénat sur la
question de la journée de la femme c'est
souvent la journée de la femme et c'est
en particulier dès mars
bienvenue dans notre partie débat au
féminin en dc l'europe car le 8 mars
nous célébrons la journée internationale
de la femme
et nous vous proposons donc de
radiographier les européennes qui
subissent de plein fouet la crise du coc
vide 19 avec quel impact sur leur santé
mentale et physique relance domestique
accès aux soins régression de leurs
droits et la cause féministe la pandémie
à modifier au quotidien à la vie de 51%
de la population vivent pourtant sur le
continent le plus progressiste en
matière d'égalité des genres et pour en
parler bien nous recevons trois
eurodéputés de la commission des droits
des femmes
karen melchior bonjour vous êtes avec
nous depuis bruxelles députée européenne
renew alors que votre pays le danemark
avec d'ailleurs les autres pays
nordiques assume historiquement un
leadership en matière de féminisme
mondial avec nous également anika brunin
du rassemblement national ce qui
correspond au groupe identité et
démocratie l'un de vos combats c'est la
lutte contre l'indifférence genre et la
france fait figure d'élève médiocre dans
la lutte contre les violences
domestiques qui ont explosé durant la
pandémie depuis séville lynagh alves
munos socialiste comme le parti au
pouvoir en espagne un pays qui à
investir depuis plus de dix ans avec
succès un combat dans la lutte contre
les violences domestiques et renforcer
le droit à l'avortement lynagh alves
munoz pour vous la pandémie est ce
qu'elle a fait régresser la cause des
femmes en europe et bonjour oui oui je
pense un peu il y a beaucoup de
différences entre les pays mais surtout
la progression je pense a été vers les
lois parce que les showmatchs défunt ça
monte beaucoup de flux que ça add ons
on ne peut pas voir on peut pas voir les
mers sultan qui est dans les dernières
crises ou là
et les travail défend surtout le travail
non payée à la maison almonte est aussi
on a fait le travail l'emploi et le
travail le marché n'a pas est remonté au
départ est entré au même que celui des
hommes et surtout parce que les
politiques publiques n'ont pas et
introduit la vision des gènes communs
comme il faut donc maintenant il faut
changer
c'était sédition et il faut l'introduire
véritablement dans les politiques dans
les bouges est aussi parce que autrement
et ça va passer au monde décrit ce
précédent
alors qu'à rennes melchior est ce que la
pandémie
c'est plus difficile à vivre avec le
confinement notamment quand on est une
femme que quand on est un homme
oui c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour
les femmes pendant la pandémie parce que
la pandémie a vraiment montré les
inégalités dans notre société les femmes
font plus ce travail dans les familles
les femmes prend soin des enfants de la
maison plus là je demande que les que
les hommes et le confinement dont les
maisons sont aussi mis en danger les
femmes qui vit dans une relation abusive
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la possibilité
d'échapper et aussi les tensions montent
et il y avait un vrai augmentation des
violences domestiques
anika bruna vous êtes d'accord avec ce
constat que la pandémie a profondément
modifié l'organisation au sein des
familles au détriment bien souvent des
femmes
oui complètement déjà je voudrais
souligner que cette crise sanitaire
aggraver les les différences qu'il
pouvait que les femmes pouvaient subir
selon leur précarité selon leur fait
qu'elles étaient entre lire ligne
comment au point de vue professionnel
est effectivement
cette crise a été un vrai problème pour
la femme
alors madame belvès mignot seul l'onu
femmes a publié en septembre les
confinements instauré pour juguler
l'épidémie du côté de 19 ans a fait
selon selon leur étude augmenter les
plaintes ou les appels aux autorités par
exemple de 30% à chypre en france et en
espagne 1 c'est vrai que vous avez tenté
de de lutter contre cela en signalant
par exemple dans les pharmacies un code
masque 19 qui veut dire je suis battu
par mon mari en quelque sorte ça paraît
un peu un peu dérisoire non comme comme
mesure où c'est nécessaire je pense que
c'est nécessaire parce que là on doit
savoir qui est même si les chiffres de
la violence contre les enfants ils sont
assez haut
c'est pas tout la violence parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup qui est encore encore
cachées et c'est normal que dans une
situation où est fermé à la maison il
faut avoir des mesures pour aider cette
femme donc je pense que c'est bien de
prendre cette mesure
il faut aussi s'assurer que les fonds
aux les trois romans et à l'opportunité
d'avoir un emploi parce que ça sera plus
facile pourrait aussi d'échapper des
situations des violences à la maison qui
ont augmenté et précisément parce que on
était enfermé avec la personne qui la
violentait quoi calmer le coeur protéger
les femmes la santé des femmes et
notamment des femmes enceintes ça vous
paraît logique je précise que la
belgique vient d'inclure les femmes
enceintes dans les personnes
prioritaires pour la vaccination
qu'ovide ça vous semble logique et ça
devrait être généralisée dans tous les
pays européens selon vous je crois aussi
c'est la situation danemark que les
femmes enceintes
en endroit pour les vaccinations plutôt
parce que les systèmes immunitaires
c'est toucher avec la enceinte
donc c'est nécessaire d'avoir la
vaccination plus plutôt que le reste est
la population qui ne sont pas enceintes
donc je crois c'est une très bonne
réponse je trouve c'est une bonne idée
pour d autres pays aussi autre que la
belgique et le danemark
puisqu'on parle de régression des droits
des femmes en pleine pandémie en octobre
dernier la cour constitutionnelle
polonaise inféodés à l'état rende est
l'une des décisions les plus
controversées de son histoire en
suspendant la principale exception à
l'interdiction d'avorter rendant donc
l'avortement totalement illégal même en
cas d'anomalie foetale pendant le
confinement le bras de fer a continué
pour le droit à l'avortement en pologne
notre reporter du l'hiver kraft 12 en
dit plus fin janvier ils étaient des
milliers dans les rues polonaise pour
réclamer le droit à l'avortement
document la contestation s'était
essoufflé mais le mouvement grève des
femmes ne veut pas baisser les bras
le verdict de la soi disant cour
constitutionnelle sur l'avortement est
désormais en vigueur
du coup nous nous concentrons sur le
plus long terme
je nous préparons à bâtir la pologne
après pis lorsque le parti au pouvoir
quittera ses fonctions désormais à
travers toute la pologne
ces affiches l'oeuvre d'une fondation
anti avortement privé malgré quelques
graffitis hostiles les femmes polonaises
n'ont plus guère d'autre choix que de se
faire avorter à l'étranger ou prendre
des pilules interdite
l'avortement reste permis en cas de
menace pour la santé de la mère certains
médecins font valoir le risque pour la
santé mentale en cas de grossesse forcé
malgré une anomalies foetales et pour
bien sûr une telle situation a un impact
négatif non seulement sur la vie et la
santé mentale de la femme mais aussi sur
celle de toute sa famille
mais l'exception sera difficile à faire
valoir une maladie mentale dangereuse
implique généralement l'internement dans
une clinique psychiatrique les médecins
vont alors insisté sur une
psychothérapie plutôt que de pratiquer
l'avortement
si les médecins sont réticents c'est
parce qu'ils risquent jusqu'à trois ans
de prison
le mois dernier le parlement polonais a
exclu tout débat sur la levée de ces
peines et les militants anti avortement
veille dans un paysage politique dominé
par les conservateurs
annick à brenac est ce que vous pensez
de cette exception un polonais sur
l'avortement est ce qu'elle doit être
tolérée par l'union européenne attachée
à la cause des femmes et je rappelle que
vous faites partie d'un groupe d'extrême
droite concurrentes celui des polonais
qui compte des militants anti avortement
est-ce que ça devient toléré alors
écoutez moi je suis très espace attaché
comme on à ce que les états membres et
les reçoit dans leur position mais
cependant les ivg et à un sujet très
très délicat et nous ne sommes pas à
s'opposer allégé dans des cas bien
spécifiques mais surtout nous sommes
très attachés au fait de ne pas dépasser
le terme de 14 semaines
en effet au bout de quatorze semaines
éthiquement parlant il ya un
développement du foetus
un qui se fait et c'est insupportable à
notre avis et en plus c'est un réel
danger pour la santé de la femme
or par contre ce qui était à déplorer
lors de cette crise sanitaire élan du
premier confinement c'est que les femmes
qui voulait avorter dans ce laps de
temps n'ai pas pu le faire et là ça a
été un réel problème effectivement donc
comme ça peut l'être en pologne alors en
pologne quand même madame galvez minos
vous avez le même un peu le
même histoire côté est côté espagnol
puisque en 2013 et bien un projet de loi
signée mariano rajoy à un conservateur
restreignez le droit à l'avortement et
il ya eu de nombreuses manifestations
qui l'ont obligé à retirer ce projet
c'est c'est un droit à défendre
activement quand vous entendez votre
voisine dires abat chaque pays fait ce
qu'il veut c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai
dans notre europe
je pense je pense pas et je pense que
les droits des enfants ils sont des
droits au maine
et quelle est la commission et doit
intervenir pour cela parce que
l'éléphant ont toujours apporté et dont
on doit savoir ça et les choses que nous
vous devons faire c'est garantir que cet
avortement
c'est fait dim des manières et secure et
pas seulement pour les enfants qui ont
l'argent pour les pour le faire donc il
faudra regarder ces trois je pense c'est
bien de respecter chaque pays mais
jusqu'aux limites et ses limites c'est
passer maintenant à pollonia avec cette
interdiction c'est mon avis car elle met
le coeur on voit avec l'exemple polonais
en 2021 malgré l'essor du mouvement mis
tout le droit des européennes à disposer
de leur corps est encore menacée est
décidée par des hommes c'est ça la
réalité en europe en 2021
ça c'est le risque en europe en voir que
en pologne
le parlement polonais a réussi avec han
han loi qui ont parait aussi qui est pas
réussi en espagne c'est en symbole c'est
cela commence mandela
dégradation de l'état de droit en
pologne c'est parce que les
gouvernements conservateurs ont pris
prises des droits constitutionnels en
pologne qu'ils ont pu faire passer cette
loi pour moi l'égalité ça commence avec
le droit de décider sur notre propre
corps et ça en plus et la droite
d'avortement oui c'est séoul dont les
shaks états membres décider si on veut
avoir ses droits d'avortement mais si on
a décidé de la voir il faut doit les
respecter pour tous pour chaque femme je
trouve c'est très important aussi que
les états membres mettent en doute et
disposition pour les femmes polonaises
pour venir faire des avortements dans
notre pays dans l'union européenne
ces endroits et européens et ça doit
être pour tous les européennes pour tous
les européens alors sur le front
économique quand même
madame bruna c'est vrai que ce sont des
femmes qui trinquent le plus on l'a déjà
noter les premières qu'on licencie en
temps de crise
vous souhaitez des mesures spécifiques
de soutien pour elle et parfois on parle
de salaire maternel mais ça n'est pas
forcément très féministe de penser
qu'une faille donner un salaire pour
rester à la maison
écoutez c'est un sujet mois auquel j'ai
envie de m'attacher parce que c'est vrai
que on dort est statutairement et
comment en terme de salaire peut
justement valoriser toutes ces femmes
qui sont à la maison on peut le noter
après en terme de retraites c'est une
catastrophe pour les femmes qui ont fait
le choix d'élever leurs enfants et donc
il devrait effectivement y avoir des
fonds alloués à louer ou une autre
d'autres mesures gouvernementales pour
protéger ces femmes surtout en terme de
retraite parce qu'elles sont très
pénalisés
lorsqu'elles ont le soin d
madame galves munos vous vous en avait
déjà parlé mais donc sur le front
économique les femmes trinquent elles
sont les premières à trinquer durant la
pandémie qu'elles sont plus facilement
licenciés et c'est pas forcément elles
qui vont être réintégrés en premier
qu'est ce que l'europe peut apporter
comme réponse pour ces femmes qui sont
mis sur le banc la société économique et
du monde de l'emploi à cause de la
pandémie
je pense qu'il l'emporté encore beaucoup
je vais te critiquent la porte et les
chouquettes et satinée instrument
important pour maintenir les de travail
l'emploi des personnes soient des hommes
que des femmes
mais on doit savoir que les les plans
d'aidé récupération ils sont surtout
pensés pour la france et sion écologique
et la transition digital et ce sont des
secteurs majoritairement avec des plots
masculin donc il faut et mettre au même
niveau eal3 une transition la transition
vers et cardio
on peut dire en anglais que c'est plus
facile d'aider d'entendre et les maîtres
ont même le autrement on ça va passer
commande et chris impressionnant donc il
faut faire un petit peu encore pas
seulement la transversalité pas son nom
les bouger mais il faut le faire avec
des syndicats terre que l'on peut suivre
aussi dans les plans national de
récupération transformation à silence un
d'indicateurs féministe en quelque sorte
que vous nous préconise et madame
melchior est ce que vous connaissez
l'expression de plafond de verre que les
femmes ne peuvent jamais dépassé parce
qu'elles sont bloquées
elle se heurte à ce plafond
économiquement avec le confinement
justement
dans les entreprises il n'y a pas eu
forcément de primes d'augmentation elles
n'ont peut-être pas été tellement
propulser en avant dans les universités
aussi a eu se distend ciel etc
et puis la difficulté à passer les
concours est-ce que ça les a encore plus
pénalisées oui parce qu'il ya toujours
ces stéréotypes des jambes à la maison
et dans la famille qui demande plus de
travail non payée du femmes des femmes
que des hommes dans les familles et donc
sa 1re en plus difficile pour les femmes
d'été avancés dans leur carrière et
aussi de se montrer en pour des
promotions
je trouve que la pandémie ça vraiment
renforcer les plafonds de verre les tous
les paris hier pour les femmes dans la
société et donc ce sera nécessaire qu'on
utilise
lara lancement pour pouvoir faire
avancer les fans et parce que l'argent
qu'on utilise pour l'heure à lancement
ça doit être utilisée pour renforcer
l'égalité et palais des dégradés merci à
vous trois d'avoir participé à ce débat
consacré à la journée de la femme en
face à de vrais êtres 365 jours par an
en fait marine on l'espère et vous
restez sur nos antennes fois la cible
des programmes
[Musique]